what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to how
pickup artists
ruined dating this is from a guy who
claims to be outside of the pickup game
and just studied pickup artists for like
a month straight
one of my followers sent this to me and
i thought it'd be interesting
before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel i'm trying
to get to 20 000 subscribers so
that would be cool okay sorry blanked
out
because done anything other than oh
shoot today i'd like to talk about
dating and if you don't remember dating
it's that thing that your parents did
with all the extra money they had from
not having to pay off college loans
if the global pandemic has done anything
other than kill millions of people and
show off the gaping holes in our
government support structure
it's made us all sadder and hornier
but while there are a lot of people i
learned
video editing but damn people on the
internet with advice on dating and
attracting a worthy partner
that's true one darker corner of the
modern human mating ritual has
perked my attention recently dating
coaches
or what used to be called pickup artists
and while the world of picking up women
may be a little mysterious to you
outside of things like the movie hitch
crazy stupid love and
that one episode of wayney days with
paul rudd it has been a
very active and influential community
from the 1990s to today
okay randy now tell me without looking
at your hand
what are the three beginner techniques
for picking i love barney that is my
favorite character picking up a woman at
a bar
isolator from her friends repeat her
name in conversation
suddenly put her down excellent damn now
before i get into it
you might be wondering brad why pick up
artists
and is your girlfriend okay with you
watching videos of speed seduction
for the past month and a half fair
question and she [ __ ]
hates it questioning if our ever
interaction is real
i'm not even gonna lie when i've been
studying pickup artist stuff
i've thought that with my boyfriend like
i've been like
has he used this stuff on what happened
was during my
hours of research watching joe rogan
videos on youtube for my last essay
don't come for joe rogan i love joe
started getting more and more targeted
ads
from dating coaches my name's christian
and one more warning
if you're a woman this presentation is
going to make you uncomfortable because
the discoveries i'm going to share about
what women want what they
secretly crave are really messed up and
i promise you've never heard this before
i guess the internet knows rogan's fan
base lonely dudes
if you have i'm a joe rogan fan
i'm i feel attacked a million people
watching a youtube video are we talking
about a hundred people that are [ __ ]
thousand is it even i don't even think
it's a thousand two hundred it might not
even be a hundred you might be dealing
with like 30 [ __ ]
the more of these ads i saw the more i
was both intrigued
and grossed out by what they were saying
so by the time i had watched joe rogan
talk about jujitsu and
call women [ __ ] roughly 200 times
sure get up here [ __ ] there's nothing
you could do to make that [ __ ] happy
this crazy thai [ __ ]
who starts slowly poisoning your drink i
had also gotten a taste
of different dating coaches theories on
how to attract women
and knew it was worth investigating who
these people are
how their philosophy affects men's
dating habits
and if there are any helpful lessons to
be learned from them
so if we were on like a coffee date or
something we're talking we'd be talking
and say
i get to get up and use the mentor i'll
be right back
well look at that expression did you see
that response
and notice the little lick lip that she
does there like
this is yummy it's only
okay this is weird because i i don't
think that guy's like attractive but
i don't know if she's attracted to him
but
that's only cute if you're attracted to
the guy i'm actually going to be making
another video after this one that
dives more specifically into the types
of youtube based dating coaches
that are currently growing in numbers
and which
tips actually take a woman's perspective
into account but this video this one
right here
will show you the beginning the
foundation
of the types of manipulative pickup
tactics
misogynistic mentalities and predatory
behavior
we see at bars clubs and on the street
today but to see that next video
and all my other content about
masculinity and how we evolve as men
subscribe to my channel and hit that
notification bell
okay so what is a pickup artist i mean
other than this guy great hair
thanks looks silky as [ __ ] whatever
is it real what well you buy it
it's a weed horse hair dumb cheap hooker
damn what are you what oh my gosh
it's usually a man who uses a
combination of psychological gymnastics
illusions hypnotism and manipulation in
order to establish their value
seduce a woman and get them to bed
welcome to my world
watch this watch this watch it
watch now now now now now now now
pickup artist or pua is a term that
sounds pretty corny to most of us today
but when pickup artist okay i'm not i
think that the
this is what art irritates me about
the mannosphere community as i already
know whatever this guy is about to say
they're going to say oh this guy's a
beta
just like based on his demeanor and it's
the same thing with me they just say oh
it's because you're a woman that's why
you think that like
but kevin samuel has been married
three times and they worship everything
he says i'm not saying the guy doesn't
speak facts
at all but in the comments guys can we
adhere
from those arguments tactics became
truly popular
mostly in the wake of the 2005 smash hit
book
the game top pickup art i ordered that
i'm going to read that just so you guys
know this were revered
wealthy and sought out by men all over
the world
and if you're wondering if i read the
game yes yes i
did read an entire book about
manipulating women for sex
so you didn't have to yeah i could just
feel my
bloodline being plagued by douche
exposure for the centuries to come
one day you will be so good at this that
you will teach it to your sons
while writer neil strauss aka style
is sometimes critical of the negative
effects of the pickup lifestyle
the game completely romanticizes the
treatment of women as
objects existing only to satisfy male
sexual desire
while also the book downplays the amount
of consistent humiliation this
philosophy causes the men
involved oh my gosh you have like the
oranges
tan i have ever seen
pickup culture is actually to blame for
now ubiquitous terms like
peacocking peacocking my outfit serves a
dual function
of icebreaker an attention getter
wingman a friend who assists you in
attracting and
taking home a woman i'm a wingman that's
what wingmen do
and negging a seemingly accidental
insult delivered to a woman to
demonstrate your lack of interest in her
when you're actually very interested oh
hell i'll give you 200 bucks to get rid
of her information
hello i'm here i'm sorry
he's given have been very like
unattractive in their demeanor to me
manipulating women for sex
began in conference halls listening to
people like the self-proclaimed
guru of gash ross jeffries oh yes
buckle up fuckleheads wait batman got
girls buckle up fucklehead this world is
full of guys
who talk about women like they are
floating pieces of soulless sex flesh
respect the [ __ ]
and tame the [ __ ]
and tom cruise's frank tj mackey from
magnolia
is not so far from the real misogynistic
philosophies
of these guys seduce and destroy will
teach you the techniques to have any
hard body blonde just dripping to wet
your
dock okay seems very weird according to
the game ross jeffries developed his
school of speed seduction in 1988
after ending a five-year streak of
sexlessness
with the help of neuro-linguistic
programming or nlp
that's a controversial fusion of
hypnosis and psychology
that emerged from the personal
development boom of the 1970s
and led to the rise of self-help gurus
like tony robbins
who also happens to be a sexual predator
wait
what tony robbins
theory inappropriate sexual advances on
fans huh the fundamental precept of nlp
is that one's thoughts feelings and
behavior and the thoughts feelings and
behavior of others
can be manipulated through words
suggestions
and physical gestures designed to
influence the subconscious
ross what do women really want i don't
care what they want
i only care what they respond to see my
focus is a little
bit different from your other guests
there's what women say they want there's
what women think they want and then
there's what they actually respond to
now that statement is actually the
bedrock of
all of jeffrey's teachings and in many
ways the teachings
of the long line of modern wannabe
casanovas to come
the pickup method to getting women into
your bed is rooted
in taking away the feelings and humanity
of a woman
and using a playbook or literal bag of
tricks
to overcome the obstacles women have
developed to keep men from
using them for their bodies what's wrong
with manipulating
let me let me hold on hold on let me
make this
manipulation i am to quote neil strauss
in the game
every part of the pickup is designed
simply to anticipate and disarm
objections and if that isn't one of the
most predatory things you've heard this
week you must
literally have velociraptors for
roommates
[Music]
i mean not only are the raptors okay i'm
just gonna give two cents
i would say that the disarming of
objections is why
there's a lot of women that are like mad
at men because they end up doing things
that they like didn't actually want to
do but these guys just like
wouldn't leave it alone or just
persuaded them whatever
like i've i have a lot of friends with
stories like that and i know the
comments is going to be filled with
people saying oh
that doesn't make it okay for them to
accuse men of sexual assault
i'm with you i agree not okay all right
i just wanted to say that
because i feel like the comment section
that's where it would go dogginess but
they don't knock before they open the
door
respect the space guys respect the
sanctity of my weird industrial kitchen
bedroom
fast forward from the 90s to the
mid-2000s an
era where maxim magazine the man show
wedding crashers californication
and tucker max's book i hope they serve
beer in hell
okay i'm sorry tucker max's book slaps i
read that a couple years ago that's one
of the funniest books i've ever read
taught young men how to be sex entitled
drunk douchebags
tattoo on the lower back might as well
be a bullseye
the message they carried if you don't
walk around with all the blood in your
body directed solely into your penis
you'll never get a hot chick to [ __ ] you
it is at this point in history where we
meet mystery
an actual magician who used his
illusions
in order to shift the dynamics of any
romantic situation
in his favor he's also the guy paul rudd
is making fun of here what's up david
i'm alias are those your clothes
yes no mystery is the example of pickup
artists that you might think of as a
little
extreme but that's why he's famous and
that's why his methods looked like they
worked
i know that this will sound very uh
egotistical
but being picked up by mystery is a
[ __ ] privilege do you know how hard i
work to make it fun for the girl
i am the most interesting person you're
likely to meet in the next 45 days
fear and excitement are the same
adrenaline release
all right this is exciting to boil down
the mystery method and practice
his steps for a successful interaction
are first
show yourself as unique from any other
guy in the current location
through either peacocking using an
interesting opening line or a
combination of both
then you establish your value through
confidence personality
intelligence and control over the
current situation
neg the target of your interest look for
iois or
indicators of interest from your target
to know that you're not wasting your
time
why am i drawn to you you need to
rationalize this for me
isolate the target or move her to
another location
in order to get closer physically and
emotionally and if that one sounds like
it's what a serial killer does
it's because it is it's a similar
mindset women have fewer options for
safety
when they're alone there are three
separate locations and the difficulty is
getting from one location to the next to
the next
do you announce it to the girl do you
say now on to sex location
and lastly close out the interaction
with the kiss
or getting her number if sex is off the
table then quickly leave as to appear
less attainable
more interesting and even more
mysterious
i am not the devil from the double
temperament
and cut to a lot of you those steps
might sound harmless or maybe even
helpful
to a woman there's a good chance they
sound incredibly menacing
and degrading before the game i actually
didn't think that was that bad
i was expecting worse i'm not even gonna
lie
because at first you just said did like
be
interesting wear something different
show her that you're different that's
not that bad
and then the second one was demonstrate
your value i'd have to
hear examples of how to do that let me
know in the comments what you think that
means
and if you guys think this is moral or
not i never heard of dating laid out as
if it were a football play
and how appealing it is for single men
many of whom have been socialized
through sports to finally have some
guidelines to follow
that have been proven to work the
problem with this
in no way do any of mysteries tips ever
include
checking in with what a woman wants to
add to the interaction
it's all a performance filled with
ridiculous gameplay costumes
and manufactured situations and this is
what i would say i agree with him
because
in a long-term relationship you're not
if you're not the type of person that's
unique and different and you're not the
type of person that's like
actually going to keep up with these
gimmicks if you want to get married
it might help you get girls sure but
is it gonna help you foster a healthy
long-term relationship probably not
i just think it's that's sort of sad to
have a method
i think it's more important just to meet
someone that you you're attracted to and
that you respect as a person
what it all boils down to is that men
like ross jeffries
mystery and neil strauss taught a
generation of lonely
horny and desperate guys that
manipulation
is the best way to get the woman of your
dreams the question is does it work
and i'm going to say this you guys in
the mana sphere say 85
of men can't get laid so
clearly not right and that idea stuck
now i want to show you i actually need
an audience's perspective on something
how do you feel about three ways lame
or progressive um sorry i'm in the
middle of a video essay here
a video essay that's cute
i've got to get back to my friends over
there in a minute but
my buddy was actually wondering if it's
a guy's place to be commenting
on what women think and feel
that's a fair question i mean my goal
with this
has been to promote empathy and kind of
hold the critical oh my god
anyone can comment on anything it
doesn't mean your opinion's right
but literally anyone can comment at
anything
did you know that you blink a lot when
you watch videos
it means that you make a lot of your
choices
from your heart okay okay flame i gotta
keep going with the video
the audience really wants me to get to
my point wow
are they always so needy i don't know
how you take them anywhere
please leave fine whatever this audience
is a youtube six instagram seven
at best damn moving on
what is completely unsurprising yet
completely insane to me about these
pickup tactics
is that they ignore the inner world of
women they disregard
the female experience i guess to these
guys
i don't care what they want i only care
what they respond to
but what about instances when women
don't feel comfortable saying no
and they're reacting out of a need to
just get it over with
what about circumstances where a woman
is complying to your sexual pressure
because of their own history with sexual
abuse
there is a ton of trauma being bypassed
and ignored
by the process of pickup artists and the
mentality of men today
and i would argue that most women's
trauma okay minus obviously if you've
been raped assaulted whatever
different category don't put that in but
for the majority the trauma that i've
seen that women have gone through is
self
picked like they pick it choose it
honestly it's something we need to look
at as the american dating male
population
never give someone an opportunity to say
no in other words
what uh you know never allow someone to
say no because there's a principle that
i'm going to teach you in a little bit
but when someone says no it sticks as a
no
so you can't allow them to say no the
two ways you do this is you can you
never ask a question
that allows for no response neil strauss
explained
more about how he and other puas saw
consent
you make out you remove her shirt she
removes your shirt
you start to remove her bra what's this
she's stopping you from going any
further
the puas have a name for this last
minute resistance or lmr
and then right when i'm about to get
into her pants she stops me
she gives me a last minute resistance
back up one or two steps then continue
wash rinse repeat it's not real it's
just
asd anti-slut defense she doesn't want
yeah
she's easy or she doesn't want to move
forward but now feels uncomfortable
pumping the brakes
and you're pressing onward without any
care for what she wants or desires or
damn that's actually shitty that's
really shitty
if a girl says no that's that's that's
shitty how she's acting
you see that there's a little difference
there after all this work all this
planning all this
game when it is finally time to take the
next step
and actually have sex how often do you
think men are asking for enthusiastic
consent
is the objective only to get your dick
wet
even if it means that the woman didn't
leave your apartment
feeling good about the encounter where
in these courses and
in these tips on picking up women is a
discussion about
checking in with how a woman is feeling
if someone
i actually agree with him right there
like do you really want to have
hook up with someone that doesn't
enthusiastically want to hook up with
you
is limp if someone is motionless blank
face staring off into space or
they have not verbally said yes those
are
all clues that you do not have consent
over 80 percent of american women have
been sexually harassed or assaulted and
a majority of female victims of rape
first experienced such victimization
early in life with 81.3
reporting that it first occurred prior
to the age of 25.
women with a past of sexual abuse have
neural pathways that kick
in when they are about to be used for
their body freezing going quiet
compliance just getting it over with
this is not consent
these are the gray areas of hookup
culture that need to be known
need to be taught need to be normalized
within the consciousness of young men
trying to get
girls yeah i mean if it was like a
self-help self-improvement thing that's
one thing
but teaching men to deliberately go out
and degrade women as sex objects is
totally wrong the prime real estate is
that hunk of kush
she's got hanging there they've learned
from their mother their aunts their
sisters
this is the piece of real estate that's
going to get you anything you want if
you learn how to work it right
and a lot of time it comes from
withholding i ask you
straight men what if you empathized with
their situation
approached women with honesty and
sincerity struck up
genuine conversations and stayed
steadfast
in the knowledge that you are worthy of
a woman
and of love as long as you're willing to
work on yourself
and not take the easy way out hey
i remember you did you know i actually
agree with that
there i mean there are shortcuts where
you can get to sleeping with women but
honestly the way that women are most
attracted to you is by improving
yourself
and there aren't shortcuts to doing it i
can tell your horoscope based on how
many times you kiss me
please flame not now not ever
actually hey can i borrow them for a
little bit i
wanted to ask them something kind of
private in that back corner over there
buy my dishwasher absolutely not did you
know that every time you think about
something your eyes go back and to the
right
that means you like to think about stuff
i wish he was making these up as a joke
and not just using lines from the game
yeah that's my cue i got to get back to
my friends but
why don't we trade into the handles and
i'll get back to you later
out out of here flame out this
generation smarter than that wait
don't you want to see me kind of make a
beer bottle levitate
i have tarot cards god do i hope we're
past the part of the human timeline
where magicians get [ __ ] more than
scientists
two three
dating is tough real connection takes
work attracting someone you find
attractive
isn't easy if you're not the most
handsome guy in the room
even hanson men have trouble finding
what they're looking for
an in-person social interaction is
getting less and less easy to
participate in in the age of covid
social media working from home our
attachment to our phone
all these things give us less practice
just being a person
with another person it would be so easy
to dismiss this entire exercise as
sexist manipulative
some might say pathetic but before you
judge you should keep in mind that some
of the men taking part in these seminars
have never in their entire lives been
able to interact socially with women
our parents hardly teach us how to do it
our schools don't
but i would agree that my parents
i like i love them to death they're a
great example of what a marriage looks
like
but since they never really dated i
don't think i had a lot of like quality
dating advice from them
pickup artists and dating coaches do
they
are fulfilling the supply for a demand
but
sometimes in the cheapest way possible
it's like if you don't like how your
face looks and
you just gotta jazzer size instead of
seeing how you are truly [ __ ]
beautiful
oh you don't know what jazzer size is
when i first saw this product i thought
it looked kind of crazy
so what i discovered is that after using
this product after maybe 100 or 200 reps
all of a sudden i feel all this blood
flow coming into my
into my face into my scalp pickup
philosophy is so
shallow it's the jaws or size of
romantic self-improvement you heard it
here folks
focusing on the sex over the connection
with another person
removes you from your own humanity your
love your empathy and i
actually would argue that
obviously like men's nature is to have
sex and like women's
um natures they want attention but that
doesn't mean you have to like
do everything according to your nature
so like you know i may like attention at
times but i'm not gonna post a bikini or
a butt picture
on my instagram like
like one of those thong stuff not my
style
just like a guy just because that's
their nature doesn't mean they have to
do it they can and they can choose to
but at what cost your soul and it turns
a woman
into something that only exists to boost
your ego or
satisfy you sexually this
is all a shallow and eventually
fruitless endeavor
any product that tells you to be less of
your true self or to pretend to be
someone else is inherently flawed the
getting girls philosophy
lowers your self-esteem and aims to
lower a woman's
so much so they feel shitty enough to
sleep with you
that's really what it is maybe that
sounds arrogant but i just know a lot
more about
things like spirituality and heart and
metaphysics and stuff like that
i know more about uh the 8 000 different
nerve endings that are
part of a woman's vagina you know i know
all the orgasm stuff like um
so i just teach them how to become
better happier people
how old are you guys i'm 30 and she's
19.
what i found through all that's such an
awkward interaction
all this is that the key to dating or
just talking to women is finding what
you're good at
what makes you you and being so
confident in that
that any rejection or invitation to
romance
cannot take it away it's a practice that
can still look like going out and
interacting with women in bars
parks on the street or online as you'll
see in my next video
but it is rooted in collaboration with
whoever you're talking to
it's fueled by mutual appreciation
empathy
and enthusiastic consent very important
handling women handling this part of
your life
is about choice and if you're so focused
on
getting better picking up girls and you
actually lose
why why it is you want women in your
life and what it is they're doing for
your life
uh you're not successful and you're not
the best
right people are people are the best
when they're with a woman and they're
truly happy
they're chilling in a great relationship
however they define their relationships
mystery here i'm currently in bali
indonesia
where damn after
25 years this is
this is what i mean like these pickup
artists it's at the cost of their soul
even
a lot of the other ones that i've
listened to like on
um different channels i mean just being
real i think the goal for everyone is to
marry someone young and be with them
like 30 40 50-year marriages that's the
goal
not whatever this guy is doing
the waters wink wink i should say
not for everyone but that sounds a lot
better than what
[Music]
so now that we know that the three
decades-old pickup philosophy and its
tactics
lead to a rejection of self uh
degradation of a woman's worth
and a sad future what now we all need
teachers and guides through new
experiences if we're having trouble with
them what are the alternatives
are there people and resources out there
now that we can
get to help men achieve their romantic
goals well
i'll have those answers and much more
about the current state of dating
coaches
in my next video here on real feels
hey folks be sure to subscribe uh i
thought that was a good video i wish he
went a little bit more in depth
on like what tactics he had a big issue
with
other than maybe the ones at the
beginning i would agree that they'll
like
keep pushing a girl even when she says
no
like that's messed up you should not
teach someone to do that
let me know in the comments if you think
that that's acceptable or unacceptable
do not forget to like
comment and especially subscribe guys
you know i'm trying to get to 20
000 subscribers that's my next goal
thank you so much
bye